احتفال تحول إلى كابوس في
قاعة للمناسبات في شمال العراق،
اجتمع هنا أكثر من ألف شخص لحضور
حفل زفاف زوجين شابين، ويظهر مقطع
فيديو على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لحظة
اشتعلت فيها النيران في السقف على ما يبدو، وأشعلت
الشرارات النيران في الديكور،
ووصف شاهد العيان كيف كان الرعب
خلال هذه الرقصة البطيئة، اصطدمت إحدى
الألعاب النارية بالسقف واشتعلت فيها
النيران دفعة واحدة، كما يقول
نسيج الفينيل يحترق كل شيء وبدأ
يسقط على رؤوس الناس ولم
يتمكن أحد من إخراج
مواد البناء شديدة الاشتعال وغير القانونية مما جعل المكان عبارة عن صندوق تندربوكس
وفقًا لـ  لوحات صدى الدفاع المدني العراقي
التي تنتهك
القانون المدني في البلاد غذت النيران وفي غضون
دقائق انهارت أجزاء من المبنى
تاركة عائلات محاصرة في
الجحيم. قال مسؤولو الجحيم إن الحروق
والاختناق أدت إلى مقتل
وإصابة العشرات وفقًا
لوزارة الصحة العراقية
بالمدى الكامل.  أصبحت المأساة
واضحة مع بزوغ ضوء النهار بينما كان
عمال الإنقاذ يدققون في الخرسانة المتفحمة
وحديد التسليح الملتوي
واكتشف أحبائهم مصير
أقاربهم
[موسيقى]
كان الأمر قريبًا وهو يحمل كل ما
تبقى من والدته، فستانها
هو بالفعل واحد من  المناطق الأكثر دمارًا في
العراق المتضررة بشدة هي كاراكوش، وهي
بلدة ذات أغلبية مسيحية،
استولى عليها داعش في عام 2014،
وأجبر جميع سكانها البالغ عددهم 60 ألفًا تقريبًا على الفرار من
غضب الجماعة الإرهابية، التي حررتها
القوات المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة بعد أكثر من عامين، وكانت الحياة تعود ببطء.
كانت زيارة البابا فرانسيس في عام 2021 بمثابة
عودة شجاعة للمجتمع المضطهد
في حفل الزفاف المسيحي هذا،
وكان ينبغي أن تكون فرصة أخرى
للسكان ليفرحوا، وبدلاً من ذلك يتساءل الضحايا عن
مدى السماح بحدوث الكثير من الموت الذي يمكن تجنبه
وما إذا كان الفساد هو
السبب.